we have been having to look pretty
heavily for it i would say for the last
four or five months but this last month
it's just become impossible to find
unfortunately for like me that i can't
breastfeed my kids i depend a lot in
formula or as my kid can't eat you would
think it wouldn't be a problem to be
able to feed your baby but
now it's really scary
how is this america this is the united
states of america
and as american mothers like the ones
you just heard from they're struggling
to feed their children
we're sending
billions and billions and billions to
eastern europe in the last hour the
house passed a bill to send another
40 billion dollars to ukraine in
military and humanitarian aid
is this even popular with the american
people
well we took the streets to do our own
little survey
the babies are coming first why not take
care of children that doesn't make any
sense i think the government needs to do
more than that they need to really think
about america and put money on the side
for our means first take care of
ourselves then we can take care of the
rest of the world i'm very sensitive to
the people who lose in their lives i'm
very sensitive to the fact that
people are dying unnecessarily
however
we have the same problems here in the
united states i don't see any of these
issues being addressed here in our own
country there's still homelessness here
there's still unemployment here
inflation
screwing
every working class person
especially young people what do you do
if you can't find
formula my daughter breastfeeds but if
you can't find a formula what do you
give your new grandson
i don't know what the appropriate amount
of money to send to ukraine is but i
think we need to take care of business
at home at the same time it's a lot
going on in america so it's like why are
we worried about overseas that's all i
got to say on that one
joining me now is jim jordan ranking
member the house judiciary committee who
voted against this massive appropriation
congressman
do your fellow lawmakers realize uh that
to the average american who is freaking
out right now about issues like baby
formula
that they're not in sync with what they
would like congress to be doing right
now
well i i think that what the the man on
the street folks you were talking to
they get it i mean think about your
typical family out there we got a
41-year high inflation rate everything
costs more for the for the moms and dads
and families that cry red costs more gas
costs more clothes costs more fun we
know that if you got a newborn
congressman
well what's congress doing you guys are
sending 40 billion
over to ukraine it's a horrible
situation what is happening in ukraine
american weakness helped create that i
understand in europe help but yep this
is just this is a
you know if you thought the ukraine
money dumped people think it was a
democrat led initiative congressman
everyone has to think again watch this
i think we all agree the most
important thing going on in the world
right now is the war in ukraine
i had a chance to call the president
last week and request
that the ukraine package
moved
by itself
and quickly
congressman meanwhile we still have an
open border
gang wars on our streets you know
homelessness uh two blocks from where
we're doing the show right now look look
look laura i understand people's
intentions i understand how bad the
situation is for the ukrainian people
what they're going through and why some
of my colleagues may have went that way
but i also understand what's happening
here in this country with record levels
of crime a border that's wide open
attorney general who tweets the treats
the very moms and dads you were talking
to as if they were domestic terrorists
and what have the democrats done in the
last two weeks last week they gave us
the disinformation governance board and
they come after our first amendment
liberties and this week they spend 40
billion on a foreign country so that's
the concern that i have and i think so
many americans have i voted for all
kinds of help for ukraine thus far but
this bill we said no look we got to
focus on the issues that count here in
america that matter to american families
and also help ukraine but do it in a way
that makes more sense than i think this
piece of legislation did particularly
the fact that we only had a few hours to
look at it for good it is insane is
another reason we should have been
against it this is insane and at the
same time we're taking the tariffs off
of the chinese goods coming into the
country which means we're helping the
country that's giving money to russia by
dumping the tariffs trump's tariffs so
figure out how we're going to present
trump that's why we need president trump
back i mean all the good things he did
uh we would not be in this situation if
if president trump are still in the
office in the oval office and i think
all your viewers know that uh well
congressman great to see you tonight
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else